well in january simon and schuster the
gargantuan publishing house
cancelled a book by a senator from
missouri josh hawley because
a mob of democratic activists told them
to it wasn't the first time they'd done
something like this did the same thing
to milo yiannopoulos several years
before
they neglected to take a second book
from best-selling author candace owens
because they didn't like her politics
simon schuster did that it's all in a
new book that i have just written
coming out in august published by simon
schuster
which you might want to check out but in
the meantime in the face of this kind of
censorship this digital book burning
there is a new
option in publishing that we want to
tell you about tonight it's called
all seasons press louise burke is the
co-founder she used to work
at simon schuster and the publisher kate
hudson is the co-founder and
editor-in-chief
together they will offer this option to
the country louise and kate
congratulations thank you for coming on
tonight we appreciate it
um so thank you
with you louise why does the country
need this
we created a for we created all seasons
press to prevent the silencing
of opposing thoughts we are fed up with
this administration
the media and big tech telling us what
to think and how to think
and at the same time indoctrinating our
children in school
they are attacking our language
and our basic right of free speech and
they're coming for everyone
well i think you're absolutely right
about that so kate how will all seasons
press be different
from say a simon schuster imprint
well as we said i mean we are we are
here for
all points of view we support the
conservative message
and they're trying to silence that
message we feel there's a real
void now that because publishers
although they're publishing some
conservative books
they're only publishing those that they
feel
don't don't
approach subjects that are considered
taboo
and so there's all of this selection
going on and
you know we're here to support the
senators the great thinkers
pundits voices who we've published
before
who are now being ignored they're being
canceled they're being censored and
so we felt that we there's really room
for us and
a void to be filled well there certainly
is a void i mean louise you've
you spent many many years in publishing
so candace owens one of the biggest
names
in publishing her first book was just a
runaway success her second book was
guaranteed to be
simon schuster could have taken it john
carp who runs it said i don't want it
purely for political reasons so the
sense that i'm getting is their politics
are more important than their revenue
that's how ideological they are
well i also think that the people who
work at the publishing houses
are trying to dictate what the
publishing houses do
it's a business first and foremost and
the woke books that they would like to
publish
are funded by some of these bigger books
that we're talking about
so um there's a little education to be
done there
wait so you're saying that when they
publish a conservative book that people
actually
read it pays for the little
boutique crazy projects that the
lunatics who work there would like to
see in print
i would say that the smaller books
absolutely are funded by the bigger
books and
you don't have to buy the book you don't
have to read the book it's america you
can
choose not to but are we not to publish
the voices
for instance of politicians who are only
in sound bites they should have the long
form
they should have the right to do so yeah
i think the times reported today that
i'm sorry go ahead kate
he said the times reported today that
there um
some publishing executives are saying
that it would be
morally unacceptable to publish books
by trump administration officials yeah
and we find a statement like that
is crazy and completely unacceptable to
us
and we're proudly in our first list
we're proudly publishing two
high-level trump administration
officials mark meadows and peter navarro
yeah well good for you and and shame on
them for abandoning the long-standing
commitment that american publishing had
to freedom of speech they've given it up
completely
and it's disgusting louise and kate
congrats i appreciate it